and welcome to Hannity we start with the
Fox News Alert tonight we are only 320
days away from the election of 2020 when
you get to decide Democrats of course
have been hell-bent on ripping this
country apart for three straight years
there are three long years of psychotic
rage hate against the president coupled
with their inability to expect accept
the outcome of We the People the 2016
election is now resulted in one of the
most if not the most pathetic divisive
disgusting repulsive and frankly
dangerous political stunts in American
history now it's been happening all day
and night this entire shift show has now
come to light it is nothing but a
revolting charade based on nothing
except they hate losing and they're sore
losers with what they have been doing
what they've been up to for three long
years has been hurting this country it's
hurting our country tonight Democrats
they seem to could care less this hour
they are all jumping for joy while
they've been pretending to be solemn and
sober and somber and whatever it's all a
lie even that's a lie to hell with the
country let's lie like we always do
let's say we did this prayerfully book
painfully all these people have done for
three years is lie and the same with
their friends and the media mob Mylo lie
again
in fact House leadership had to ask
their members not to perform their
victory dance in public instead they
were instructed to act somber no
high-fiving now pretty tall order for
some as Democrats they have been
dreaming of this moment for three plus
years in fact it is been in the works
since before Donald Trump was even the
Republican nominee I kid you not let's
go to Politico April 26 2016 could Trump
be impeached shortly after he takes
office impeachment is already on the
lips of pundits newspaper editorials
constitutional scholars who not scholars
and even a few members of Congress one
of those members of Congress was yes
nutty Jerry Nadler himself he chaired
the Democrats one week one week in
each man preceding sham proceeding his
own ship show view all in the Judiciary
Committee with ivory tower professors
one of which wanted to impeach Trump for
tweeting out the words fake news and in
November 2016 right after the election
nutty Nadler exclaimed quote we can't
wait for years to vote mr. Trump out of
office so we must do everything we can
do to stop Trump and his extreme agenda
that was November 2016 a few months
later on January 20th 2017 19 minutes
after President Trump was sworn into
office as the 45th president of the
United States there is the Washington
Post declaring the campaign to impeach
Trump has begun now we know what's going
on here Hillary Clinton was totally
destroyed by Donald Trump the Democrats
the media mob they never saw this coming
you we the people well we decided to
elect a disrupter an iconoclast somebody
who made promises and was hell bent on
fulfilling them president one sore
losers in the Democratic Party the media
mob the deep state they have been
plotting their revenge ever since even
before first was Russia Russia Russia
collusion collusion collusion conspiracy
conspiracy obstruction obstruction taxes
and then it was campaign violations then
back to Russia
now the Ukraine will move they're too
vague cooked up what are absolutely
meaningless charges featuring zero
evidence we have one fact witness
restful hearsay and opinion witness one
fact witness what is it what do you want
nothing no quid pro quo by the way
unlike Joe I wonder what the real look
at Joe and zero experience hunter you're
not getting the billion unless you fire
the guy that's investigating my son
who's zero experience making millions
yeah the very thing they say they're
outraged about now Pelosi shift Nadler
they're really interested in the abuse
of power they got to look in the mirror
because the shift show in Congress that
we've been witnessing all day
there is real abuse of power it is them
now let's make one thing perfectly clear
tonight this is not just about President
Trump this is about
yep you we the American people we smelly
Walmart shopper Trump supporters we
irredeemable deplorable z' that cling to
our God our Constitution and our Bibles
Democrats think that we the American
people we we're really dumb they think
they know better they clearly look down
on us they detest our way of life they
don't like our politics our religion our
choices or our candidates and the way we
vote and they believe that everyone on
this map should be ruled by lawmakers in
New York in California San Francisco LA
New Jersey New York sure in DC that's
not how our system works is it we have a
constitution or a constitutional
republic we're protected from this kind
of far left radical statism and tyranny
this impeachment charade
there's Ukrainian nonsense coup attempt
will be immediately dismissed in the US
Senate and then the will of we you the
American people will prevail you will
have all the power in three hundred and
twenty days because what we've been
witnessing all day and all night I'll
tell you is nothing but political
theater I do have good news all of its
helping the president they are
contributing to the re-election of
Donald Trump how do we know look at this
brand-new Gallup poll the president's
approval rating is up and support for
impeachment is down dramatically in fact
the president's approval rating is up
six points since the entire shift show
started and meanwhile a new USA Today
poll has the president beating every
single potential Democratic rival
Americans know a political sham and a
witch-hunt when they see it for three
straight years and as per usual the
president he is fighting back you see
that rally earlier tonight thousands of
people packed in an arena it's the
greatest political show on earth they
couldn't give a flying rip with these
people that have been hell-bent on
stopping destroying not helping us not
doing a thing think about this can you
name in your own mind one thing that
they have done to help this country to
help the Forgotten men and women let's
see 13 million more Americans on food
stamps 8 million more in poverty Louis
labor participation rate since the 70s
that was Biden Obama Trump 7
million fewer people on food stamps
seven million new jobs the best
employment situation since 1969 Wow
record low unemployment African
Americans Hispanic Americans Asian
Americans women in the workplace youth
unemployment what are the Democrats done
can you think of one thing except
painting Trump we are 320 days and then
you get the power Democrats they
probably know deep in their hearts mmm
they're not going to do well now this
radical extreme socialist agenda this
field of 2020 so-called contenders yep
they're great keep it up quid pro quo
Joe he's corrupt to the core and he
brags about it zero experience hunter
paid millions he's leveraging a billion
US tax dollars and the mob won't talk
about it
and Democrats ignore it that's how
bifurcated and messed up their brains
are tonight that's how hypocritical they
all are and by the way they can in the
case of quid pro quo Joey can barely
string two sentences together without
getting confused then you got Elizabeth
Warren dishonest karna Kahn owners their
entire career radical socialist faked
her own race for decades and you got the
angry socialist communist Bernie Sanders
well he wants us to look like Venezuela
and you got mayor Pete he's not even
loved in his own town that's a problem
now it's pretty obvious this impeachment
charade is not just about revenge it's a
desperate political ploy it is a power
graph
Democrat Al Green congressman said well
we don't impeach the president he's
gonna get reelected
congresswoman Alexandria Cascio Cortes
saying this is about preventing a
potentially disastrous outcome from
occurring next year and just today the
corrupt compromised coward congenital
liar
the man himself Adam Schiff echoed those
concerns
what solicited the president has made
clear he's not going to stop seeking
foreign intervention or election he's
out on the White House lawn saying that
if we're being honest there's a simple
answer I want Ukraine to do this
investigation the timing is really
driven by the urgency and that is
national security issue
yes a national security issue an issue
of our election integrity if the
president is seeking still to
essentially cheat in the next election
that is not a remedy for his misconduct
the remedy is impeachment and that's why
we've moved forward and we've done so
you know methodically but nonetheless
with a sense of urgency the congenital
like please come on the show give you a
full hour full out and I'm going show on
cable come said talk anyway he's worried
about losing again in 2020 what we're
seeing here is every part of it as a
disgusting pattern that has now gone on
three straight years Democrats always
looking for ways to rig the system now
they've used the IRS to target
conservative and Tea Party groups they
use the FBI we now know it's all
confirmed everything we've told you for
almost three years to spy on the Trump
campaign transition and deep into the
Trump presidency they call for the
Electoral College to be abolished they
want to stack the courts in a scheme to
manipulate the US Supreme Court so they
can legislate from there and now they're
using the very serious tool of
impeachment because they want to alter
the outcome of an upcoming election and
meanwhile the president accomplished it
but after accomplishment after
accomplishment we could go on the
Washington Examiner well put a couple
hundred up there if you want to read
them President Trump has been busy in
spite of the most difficult
circumstances out there keeping his
promises he's working to improve the
lives of Americans make us more
prosperous try and make us more safe and
more secure and keeping his word tax
cuts ending and a burdensome regulation
energy-independent net exporter of
energy for the first time in 75 years
he promised freer fairer trade deals
we've got it prison reform done the
right to try and that's done by the
president meeting is sick you want to
try something you have the right to do
it building the wall on our southern
border yep he got that done too he's
finally got the money in spite of zero
help destroying the Isis Caliphate by
taking off the ridiculous handcuffs
rules of engagement from the Obama era
Baghdady dead along with his associates
the list goes on and on look at our
economy one record after another that is
now being set set in this country no
political stunt is going to slow down
the President's agenda and on November
3rd and 320 days you we the American
people we get the final say the choice
for president is going to be clear